hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
answer a question from one of my face
book readers Brayden who's launching a
clothing company and one of my advice on
how to get started so we wrote insane do
you have any good success stories about
clothing companies I've started my own
company rain city royalty bushes Empire
and it's just starting to take off I'd
love to hear and advice you have for
getting about the ground so thanks for
the question Brayden first off we do
have a lot of famous entrepreneur
profiles on the website Calvin Klein
your Germany and a number of others and
it shows how they got started so I
definitely suggest reading those
profiles either on our site or doing
your own research I found when I started
my business that it was incredibly
helpful to research other people who had
been in my industry and achieve success
and to model their strategies to know
kind of shortcut all the mistakes they
made and follow the path to success so I
found that really helpful just getting
their ideas but also staying motivated
because you see they had dark days and
they had trouble and being able to model
that that success and see that they had
problems kind of gave me the courage to
keep going hopefully it will for you so
definitely it's a good place to start in
terms of hot my advice for for helping
you get off the ground the big challenge
I see a lot in the clothing industry
people want to start up as they spend a
ton of money and it's an expensive
business to start because you have a lot
of product that you create and you don't
necessarily have a lot of sales right it
could be hard you pick the wrong t-shirt
and it bombs and now you're stuck with
all this inventory that you kind of load
so I'd really try to focus on not
spending a lot of money trying to
minimize your cost as much as possible
preserve your cash to let you last as
long as possible and try to not spend
much money until you're making money
right anybody can spend money but you
want to try to get as close as you can
to get in cash in the door before you
start spending a lot of money on
promotion so that's the first thing
second thing in a practical strategy for
you to try to copy is to partner up so
look of guys who already sell into your
target market
if they maybe they're already selling
clothes or the selling other products
your target market I don't know who
you're selling to if its students for
example you want to try to partner with
other companies who sell to students and
it could be another clothing company or
unrelated company but has your same
target market and try to partner up with
them to have them help you sell and they
get some kind of cut for it either a
percentage of revenue that's ideal or
you pay them a small fee to help promote
you so if there's a trade show for
example again if you're gonna have two
college students something on campus or
if it's in a shopping mall or a
convention or some kind of trade show
you know somebody's going you offer to
take a small part of their table like an
eight to the table or a third of their
table something something small you
either again a revenue split or some
kind of some kind of upfront fee but
hopefully not too much and you see if
that's if that's the right market for
you so you're not spending a whole lot
of money you're not getting your own
booth for example your takes taken a
small part you get to talk to your
potential customers you get to see if
they like what you're doing or not
hopefully you can make some sales and
you can figure out okay these designs
really work these ones don't you know
people are asking me for something that
I'm not making yet so there's an
opportunity for me to make some more
money and hopefully by talking to enough
customers in his low cost away as
possible you'll be able to get some
feedback and they'll start producing
some clothes that people really enjoy
the last thing is I I try to see the
product intelligently as much as you can
so try to give your products of people
who might be able to help promote you
and showcase it for example and again I
don't know who your target market is but
when I row back to you to say I'm making
a video for you offer to send a t-shirt
right I don't usually wear t-shirts in
the videos but I might write if it's
talking about your company and that's an
opportunity to get me promoting you on
YouTube and to the people who are
watching the video so whoever you're
talking to see if there's an opportunity
to potentially see the product and get
people wearing it in a way that exposes
you and gets your name out there and
hopefully you can some you'll make some
sales that way as well but I think
you're
best strategies through the partnership
again looking for low-cost ways be able
to talk to your customers hopefully make
a few sales and also see what new
products you cannot launch to be able to
satisfy their needs so thanks for the
question Braden for those of you
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below I always love
seeing those coming in and gives you the
motivation to make more videos for you
and give a comment about this video or
question for your own company feel free
to leave in the comments below I always
read those and try to respond to
everybody as soon as I can so thank you
and that will see you next episode
you